[Musique]
oui mais ma parole autochtone si c'est
une somme lundi puis alors cette semaine
je pense que je peux pas éviter le sujet
de la semaine c'est pas le sujet des
deux dernières années c'est à dire le
verdict de culpabilité envers des restes
humains pour sa participation dans la
mort de georgetown
il a été reconnu coupable de meurtre au
second et au troisième degrés il a été
reconnu coupable et responsable du fait
qu'il ait mis son poing on évalue à
environ 91 points 5 livres de son poids
avec son équipement sur les voies
respiratoires de georges feydeau et je
pense estime le plus troublé dans toute
la semaine c'est le fait qu'on a tout
lancé un soupir de soulagement est
coupable mais ce que je trouvais
vraiment atroce et tous les vidéos qui
avait tourné bien détourné en deux
angles tout montrer vraiment minute par
minute que la personne est vraiment pour
des actions dangereuses que des
réchauffeurs vraiment mis son poing que
la personne et on est encore à se dire
est ce qui va être reconnu coupable
donc je pense que c'était une plus
dommageable c'est que ça devient
quasiment une en les services policiers
et les populations à risque c'est à dire
des populations racisées comme au canada
et au québec on à ces enjeux là
peut-être pas au même niveau puisque le
port d'armes n'est pas celui des etats
unis
mais on voit quand même distinction en
défendre des populations
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que souvent la
même dans les dernières années on a
parlé beaucoup du terme à six est riche
à esprit pop je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de
dire de reconnaître parce que ces deux
termes qui présentement dans le contexte
social dans lequel on existe malgré le
fait que les races n'existent pas le
système qui est en place qui reconnu de
façon consensuelle par la population lui
il existe et il est assise est ce à dire
mais une réforme et une classe raciale
sur des membres de la population donc
sur un moment je vois pas les races mais
arrêtez vous pour les personnes qui
vivent ces déséquilibres dans les
services qu'ils reçoivent dans le
système auquel ils sont confrontés dans
leur relation par exemple avec les
policiers avec les soins de santé qu
station aux etats-unis au canada au
québec
ils le savent ils le voient eux que j'ai
souvent dû via lisez ça d'une manière
des fois je trouve ça tellement léger
mais j'expliquais dernièrement j'ai dit
c'est comme une allergie aux arachides
beaucoup de gens dimanche pas large aux
arachides on dérange pas les arachides
mais quelqu'un qui est allergique aux
arachides elle le sait elle voit en
danger elle le vit et peut avoir une
rencontre avec l'allergène qui peut lui
être mortelle malheureusement c'est la
meilleure manière que j'ai eue de
pouvoir expliquer comment pour un groupe
de personnes il n'y a pas d'enjeu et
pour un autre groupe est un enjeu
marqueur
donc dans le cas de georges frêche je
pense que c'est ce soupir collectif et
qui a été ressenti autant à montréal que
au fin fond du sud des états unis
parce qu'à on le sait qu'ils ont des
idées on sait qu'il ya un prêt une
problématique de brutalité policière on
sait qu'un racisme systems ise qui fait
partie du quotidien et déjà et on le
voit quotidiennement à travers des
vidéos youtube
beaucoup de gens c'est pourquoi il est
plus en plus de brutalité policière n'y
en a pas plus en plus c'est juste plus
souvent filmé et plus de témoins et de
plus en plus de gens vont avoir le
réflexe de sortir le téléphone et de
films et l'interaction au cas où la
personne aurait besoin d aide
et je pense qu'au québec il ya
une compréhension dits dangereux qui
vient du fait que pendant le printemps
arable on a vu la nécessité d'avoir des
vidéos des journalistes indépendants qui
se promenait dans les manifestations et
on voyait justement souvent des
interactions problématique donc le que
le judge dredd est quand même un moment
charnière
parce qu'il ya un sentiment d'injustice
ne devrait pas avoir avoir ce sentiment
de retenir notre souffle et de donner
autant d'énergie et d'efforts pour
pouvoir s'assurer telle injustice cette
justice ne devrait viser légal ressentie
par la population dont on sait elle ne
l'est pas faut pas oublier que ces
injustices et ce racisme cette
discrimination le remonte à pas très
longtemps dans l'histoire je dérive non
et je dis c'est pas uniquement allegro
petit les livres précisé qu'ils en ont
vécu mais c'est un ajustement de
déséquilibre dans la société et le
présentement on parle justement de cet
enjeu car on est une personne assise et
où une personne qui vient d'une
communauté à risque dont on comprendrait
que c'est un moment extrêmement sensible
et d'ailleurs on voit aussi dans les
médias sociaux dans les commentaires
dans l'est quand je faisais la liberté
d'expression de certaines personnes par
téléphone entre les mains qu'il ya une
justification de ce qui s'est passé qui
a une compréhension de pourquoi policier
a droit de se mettre à genoux sur le dos
quelqu'un l'a empêché de respirer et
donc beaucoup de gens qui vont même à
les commenter
pour dire qu'ils comprennent pourquoi la
police en fait c'est un gars doux tout
est là alors qu'on roule jamais
normaliser une excès de violence c'est
un privilège d'être un agent de la paix
ce privilège qui devrait aussi une
grande responsabilité et de revenir avec
une confiance de la population envers le
travail qui est fait il ya un gros
travail de décolonisation et de
confiance à rebâtir dans cette relation
avec les populations afro descendantes
aux états unis avec les populations
autochtones au canada au québec et
beaucoup d'autres groupes qui subissent
justement souvent un service à deux
vitesses
donc vous comprendrez que c'est
extrêmement sensible qu'on prend avec
beaucoup de gens qui sont touchés par le
verdict et les etats unis c'est pas une
américanisation des enjeux c'est que ça
se connecte avec des réalités qui vit
ici au canada
donc je souhaite une belle semaine
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir prendre un
souffle et espérer que la société à
crème de ces nouvelles situations de ce
nouveau revirement je demande justice
ils composent aller de l'avant et créer
cette société qui voit sécuritaire pour
nos enfants soit une baisse à man
n'hésitez pas à partager ses vidéos
n'hésitez pas non plus à nous envoyer
vos questions